and finally new rule American politics
must be introduced to a new concept
catch 23 now of course catch-22 meant if
you claim to be insane to get out of
combat it actually proved you were
saying catch 23 is if Donald Trump never
makes you insane
you are insane I bring this up because
Republicans love to throw out the term
trump derangement syndrome to deflect
any criticism from the Dear Leader and
by that they mean that liberals are a
bunch of sore losers who just can't
accept the results of an election and
they go mental what every little thing
Trump does and there is a bit of that on
the left but have you watched this man
over the last four years let me call the
Russians we want deal Bing Bing I don't
want mosquitoes around me I'm wearing a
jacket and I had tippy top shape we got
to this we got to that I don't know what
I said I said let's go to a rare thank
you very much
[Applause]
and you came to the conclusion yeah
that's how a president behaves and I'm
the one who's deranged you know when
Republicans say Democrats never got over
Trump's behavior you're right we haven't
gotten over it because no one should
anyone remember otto warmbier a college
kid who kim jong unkilled and trump said
Kim tells me he didn't know about it and
they take him at his word same thing he
said when the Saudis killed Jamal
khashoggi when the entire American
intelligence community told him Putin
had interfered with our election he
sided with Putin when they told him Kim
was still testing missiles he said we're
in love
nothing Mitch McConnel this is what
Trump derangement syndrome really is
pretending that all of this is perfectly
acceptable behavior
that's deranged that's a syndrome and
it's coming from the right it's like
body odor if you smell it all the time
it's probably you look I don't have time
to go through all of Trump's greatest
hits so let's just say if you don't
think a president doing this is crazy
then I just want you to know that if Joe
Biden rapidly declines and legit loses
his mind then I am going to pretend
nothing to see here just like you're
doing now and I am going to encourage
all Democrats to do the same and vote
for him anyway and I'm not talking about
the current Joe Biden not the mildly
embarrassing gaffe machine who mixes up
stories and waits till he's on stage for
his eyeball to explode
and his dentures to fall out that guy
would not be nearly broken and crazy
enough to teach the Republicans the
lesson they need to learn for this I
need Joe Biden to be full-on forgot to
wear pants crumbs in his hair screaming
at the toaster nuts and when Republicans
say wait a minute how can you give
unwavering support for someone who's
clearly lost it I'll say I don't know
you tell me
and just like you do now
in private Oh we'll all admit oh yeah
our guy's nuts but publicly we'll say is
great full denial mode like you do now
you don't believe he's ever like he
exaggerates and spins okay do you
believe he's ever told the American
people a lie no Wow with friends like
that who needs a sharpie
Donald Trump doesn't lie that's where
they are
okay fine but when crazy senile pants
pissing Joe Biden his president and
gives the medal of freedom to the
Pillsbury Doughboy I'm just going to say
he's a different kind of President Trump
humps the flag I want Joe to [ __ ] it
[Music]
because he's not a traditional president
I want him always wandering off I want
to see a headline missing for three days
President Biden found sleeping in a
mattress go
I want him to have an extramarital
affair with blac Chyna
and every [ __ ] up thing a celebrity
ever did I want to see him do it I want
to see him eat a hamburger off the floor
I want to see an interrupt Taylor Swift
at an award show block a hooker in a
closet shave his head and attack a car
with an umbrella I want to see him jump
up and down on Oprah's couch in a meat
dress
and after he plows the presidential
limousine through a farmers market I
will say why so upset Republicans that's
just Biden being Biden
you